[Musique]
dernière émission de l'année on se dit
qu'on ferait ça quand même en présentiel
comme on le dit souvent pour revoir
revisiter cette année qui était très
marquante elle a commencé comment on
s'en souvient avec l'aso au capitole le
6 janvier j'ai vraiment rappelle qu'un
tas de ta réaction directe qu'on a
commencé à s'écrire à ce sujet là il
faut qu'on commence par ça ça m'a
vraiment donné le coup en ce qui a trait
la désinformation et aux conséquences
concrètes la désinformation laurie
l'année en partie en gras dans le monde
à des informations un assaut sur le
capteur pour arrêter le transfert de
pouvoir au sein de l'appareil politique
américain quand même jamais vu ça a
choqué la planète entière c'est un
événement qui a été on va se dire
entièrement portée par la désinformation
électorale ces gens l'aient attaqué le
capitole parce qu'ils croyaient
faussement que l'élection avait été
truqué on peut pas juste parler de
désinformation web parce que bon le
l'ancien président américain dans
l'autre on peut quand même me fais ça
par la propagation pour ce nouvelles sur
l' élection américaine vers les anciens
compassionnel aussi oui exactement armée
mais quand même il ya un groupe à 2 ce
qui des informations sur le web
d'ailleurs
l'assaut sur la capitale est en grande
partie organisée à même les réseaux
sociaux donc facebook qui dit non la
soupe ce qu'apple a été organisée sur
des plateformes chiffrés comme
télégramme ou whatsapp des choses comme
ça oui par contre les gens étaient
invités à ces canaux là dans des groupes
facebook qui portait qui remettait en
question l'issue de l'élection
américaine des groupes facebook qui ont
explosé en termes d'abonnés dans les
jours qui ont suivi l'élection dans les
semaines qui ont suivi l'élection donc
sa survie deux sortes de questions sur
le rôle des réseaux sociaux là dedans et
des questions qui sont vraiment pas
évidente donc les réseaux sociaux comme
facebook twitter youtube qui ont pris
une décision quand même une listed
d'année le président américain en
fonction donc dans notre chambre qui
était toujours
président américain entre le 6 janvier
et le 20 janvier où il ya eu le
transfert de pouvoir le nouveau
président joe biden les plateformes
jugeait qui posait un risque de propager
des informations dangereuses donc c'est
du jamais vu ce sont des décisions qui
sont loin de faire l'unanimité
ça pose des clôtures des questions
extrêmement complexe sur le pouvoir des
réseaux sociaux décidé qu'ils doivent
s'exprimer quand le président mir king
en même pas le droit de s'exprimer à
aimer réseaux sociaux c'est vraiment pas
évident ça pose en précédent qui va
marquer les années à venir c'est certain
parce que c'est la même chose venait à
se passer dans un autre pays qui a un
groupe qui remet en question une
élection qui décident de porter des
actions
envers les institutions politiques mais
là on va dire facebook vous avez banni
dans l'offshore vous devez bernier tel
politiciennes ou tel membre de parti
donc c'est pour régler et on va encore
subir les soubresauts du 6 janvier pas
seulement l'année prochaine dans les
années à venir c'est certain jusqu'à
présent ne pas mentionner le mot kobe 19
et pourtant et pourtant parce que
blizzard ouf enfin marie pier boutin a
eu pourtant d'argent cette année les
infos basé sur la cabine est déconseillé
à un moment donné dit naïvement que
peut-être l'on allait moins parler de
kovy de cette année qui allait falloir
trouver autre chose ah ah ah mais oui
mais c'est certain que la vaccination
qui a commencé en décembre 2020 donc été
un gros moteur de désinformation
on pouvait faire un survol exhaustif de
toutes les forces nouvelles qui ont
circulé mais elles qui ont vraiment pris
beaucoup de place par exemple on a
beaucoup dit que les le développement
des vaccins il avait été bâclée trop
rapide expérimenté vous voyez on s'est
attaqué à sa maintenance fois
parce que les étapes elles ont été
suivies malgré tout ce qui a été
véhiculé c'est certain qu'on était dans
un contexte tellement particulier
se sait jamais arrivé look autant de
ressources d'énergie d'argent tout le
savoir du monde converge dans une seule
et même direction c'est du jamais vu
puis c'est normal donc que la rapidité
avec laquelle on a développé ses vaccins
là ce soit du jamais vu aussi mais
c'était vraiment sale tout au long de
l'année venant le fil conducteur
ça a été la vaccination les campagnes de
vaccination et la vaccination pour les
enfants mais là ça a été oui c'est ça
puis à force d' alimenter ces craintes
l'oeil est pas surprenant aussi quelque
chose qu'on a vu sur j'ai assez souvent
c'est toutes sortes de traitements
alternatifs
mon a beaucoup parlé d'ivermectine de
vitamine d on a quand même beaucoup
critiqué plusieurs des essais cliniques
justement qui avait été menée sur l'idh
roxy chloroquine les travaux de didier
raoult figure emblématique
s'il en est une ont été beaucoup
critiquée en 2021 ça nous a peut-être
aussi permis de prendre conscience du
fait que c'est pas parce que quelqu'un
un bon sarraut les lettres doctor who
phd entourant son nom que c'est
nécessairement un gage de crédibilité et
il ya eu une petite remise en question
autour de saulcy juge pas alors qu'avant
les traitements étaient mis de l'avant
pour dire que qu'on pouvait stopper la
pandémie maintenant c'est qu'on met en
opposition les traitements et vaccins
c'est ce discours qu'on voit plus
souvent maintenant on dirait que ces
traitements là je ne sais pas pourquoi
saussez on les veut on les attend puis
meilleur quand même des traitements le
qui pourrait être prometteur on crache
pas sur tout ce qui pourrait être
traitement mais c'est certain que le
traitement le qui fait qu'on pourrait se
passer du vaccin il n'existait pas tout
ça parce beaucoup aussi par des bottes
de mentionné jeff tantôt youtube
facebook twitter toc toc toc toc c'était
vraiment nous décrypteurs un réseau
social sur laquelle une application sur
laquelle on s'est beaucoup attardé
nicolas une application qui peut nous le
tir depuis 2016 que ces applications le
existe
popularité auprès des jeunes n'ont pas
cette année conclut ont franchi le cap
du milliard d'utilisateurs mais j'ai
l'impression qu'en 2021 techno qui est
vraiment venu sur le radar des médias
qui couvrent la désinformation qui
couvre les réseaux sociaux vont a vu
vraiment surtout au québec au canada
français une explosion la désinformation
sur techtoc et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les vidéos sur techtoc peuvent
être les charges et ensuite téléverser
sur d'autres réseaux sociaux faict ce
qu'on a observé dans l'équipe c'est que
justement beaucoup des vidéos sur
facebook surtout même en fin d'année qui
sont devenu viral venait de techtoc et
la question de du travail qu'a fait
techtoc pour modérer la désinformation
je pense que l'était davantage mises de
l'avant cette année il ya eu plusieurs
enquêtes de plusieurs médias notamment
aux états unis donc il va falloir voir
ce qu'il va faire techtoc à l'avenir
pour s'attaquer à ça est-ce qu'on n'a
pas encore une preuve cette année du
fait qu'ils les fameuses algues au
rythme que tu évoques nous pousse assez
rapidement vers des contenus liés à la
désinformation c'est ce qu'on a vu dans
notre test sur l'algorithme de tik tok
c'est ce qu'on a vu dans notre test sur
la grille de tik tok c'est quelque chose
que je pense et plus rentrer dans la
conscience populaire année avec les
facebook fait aux aussi je veux dire ça
fait ça fait plusieurs années que des
personnes qui s'intéressent à ces
questions le disque effectivement les
algues des réseaux sociaux vont nous
montrer du contenu qui nous pousse à
réagir et que ce qu'ont eu le bon
contenu parfois plus extrêmes du contenu
qui peut être des informations est ce
que les facebook va vous montrer c'est
effectivement ce que les gens
soupçonnaient était vrai l'on se
souvient francis à hogan 7 lanceuse
d'alert qui a fait couler document
interne de facebook qui disait que la
compagnie prises de profits
sur la sûreté des utilisateurs cette
lumière la été mis sur facebook cette
année mais c'est un problème généralisé
merci c'est une chose positive avec tik
tok c'est qu'il y en ait fait beaucoup
de jeunes là dessus il c'est rentré dans
la conscience populaire que l'algorithme
de tétouan qui est super bon pour te
connaître peut-être que ça va éveiller
les consciences que les gens se posent
la question d un jeune âge dès les
premiers balbutiements que les réseaux
sociaux mais si je vois cette
publication là pourquoi est ce que je la
vois un qui décide ce que je vois mon
nom mon fils d'actualité lentement mais
sûrement je pense qu'il ya une réflexion
qui se fait au sein du public